لكم التحيه انا الان داخل مدينه بورسودان
وداخل القياده العسكريه وداخل غرفه
العمليات المتعلقه باجلاء الرعايه
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه ازعج جدا في هذا
المباشر الخاص لقناه العربيه انكم بمعيه
اللواء صلاح بابكر عمر ابو حسبه قائد
الفرقه 101 مشاه بحريه ورئيس لجنه الاجلاء
للبعثات والرعايه الدبلوماسيه وكيف مضت
هذه العالمي العمليه واي مرحله وصلتها
الان بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الكريم حقيقه
العمليه بدات يوم 21/4 باذن الله الرعايه
وحقيقه تشكلت لجان وخلايا
لتسهيل هذه العمليه ولتامين حركه البعثات
من الخرطوم الى بورسودان بدات
بعدد خمسه سفن يوم 21 سفن سعوديه سفن
حربيه سعوديه
حقيقه راعينا يعني راعينا انه الناس جايه
من ظروف نفسيه معينه حاولنا نسهل كل
الاجراءات المتعلقه
بالمواني بدخول السفن
ورباطه وايضا بوصول الرعايه هنا وتجميعهم
وضيافتهم وما الى ذلك من من اجراءات حقيقه
كانت عمليات الاجلاء يعني بطريقه سلسه جدا
سهلنا كل الاجراءات حتى الاجراءات الرسميه
للجوازات
والجمارك كانت في مكان استقبال هذه
الجاليات كيف يتم التنسيق من التحرك من
العاصمه الخرطوم الى هذه المدينه في شرق
السودان هل من عقبات امنيه واجهت البعثات
والرعايه
حقيقه يعني بعض تحركهم من خارج الخرطوم لا
توجد اي مشاكل حدثت بعد المشاكل داخل
الخرطوم قبل تحرك بعض البعثات لانه
الخرطوم يعني شويه على الكنترول كان صعب
شويه لكن بعد خروج طوال احنا بنتم متابعته
عبر الفرق المختلفه في الشارع حقيقه العمل
ده تم بترتيب قياده منطقه البحر الاحمر
العسكريه ونحن حقيقه تقريبا يعني شكرا
جزيلا للسيد غاده المنطقه لمتابعه الدقيقه
لهذا الامر
حتى وصولهم هنا بتكون الاجراء كل
الاجراءات اكتملت للدخول والرباط السفن
واكتمال الاجراءات الخاصه بالجوازات
والهجره ما حجم القطعه البحريه التي يبدو
انها في طريقها الان لبورسودان وعدد من
تبقى في طريقهم من السودان الى خارج
السودان
الان الان نحن بصدد عندنا الان بتحمل
ثلاثه سفن اللي هي سفن من المملكه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعندنا سفينه هنديه
وعندنا سفينه كوريه جنوبيه وفي انتظار عدد
اخر من السفن الحقيقه
حجم التنسيق ايضا بين الجيش بين الامن
البحري بين الشرطه هذه الامور تحتاج الى
تنسيق وعدد الرعايه الان في ازدياد في
بورسودان كيف تواجهون كل هذه التحديات
والانظار كلها متجهه صوب المطار وصوب
الميناء لا الامر المسيطر عليه تماما
الحمد لله رب العالمين هنالك ليان وخلايا
تعمل على مدار الساعه 24 ساعه ليل نهار
لتسهيل هذه المهام وفي تنسيق تام جدا يعني
لا توجد اي
سلبيات يعني الان حتى الان كل العمليات
تتم بدقه شديده جدا وحتى الناس الجو وتم
يقلاون يعني حتى ما حسوا بانه في اجراءات
ولا حسوا بانه في تقدس او طوابير يعني كل
كل المهم المهمه طلعت بصوره سلسه وطيبه هل
وصلتكم اي رسائل او برقيات للخروج من
السودان سواء كان عرفنا بان التايلاند
الان في الطريق الى ان تبعث وترتب لي تخرج
رعاياها هل من دول اخرى الان تنسق معكم
حتى تجلي رعاياها من السودان عبر بورسودان
اقصد هنا نعم بالتاكيد يعني كله كله كله
على مدار صعب نستلم طلبات
لدخول سفن يعني انا قبل وصولكم هنا بنصف
ساعه وصلتنا طلب لسفينه هنديه اخرى وايضا
يتم للسفينه كوريه
وما زالت طلبات مستمره يعني اكبر الجاليات
التي وصلت الجاليه الهنديه كيف تواجهون
اخراج نحو 1000 هندي من السودان
والله تم الترتيب لذلك ما في اي مشكله
الامور كلها طيبه وصل اليوم الصباح والان
هم مؤسفين موجوده داخل الميناء وهم في
النقاط بتاع التجمع ومنتظرين اكتمال هذه
الاعداد يعني لا تريد اي مشاكل لا توجد اي
شكاوي ونحن يعني الاجتهاد كبير جدا
بحيث انه تتم العمليات بصوره طيبه كيف
السؤال الاخير كيف يتم توفيقه اوضاع من
فقد الاوراق الثبوتيه الاشتباكات التي
حدثت في الخرطوم جعلت كثير ممن وصلوا الى
شرق السودان من غير اوراق ثبوتيه هل
باستطاعه الغرف المعنيه بالجوازات ان تسهل
وتمهد الخروج الان من السلس من دون اي
عقبات او تعقيدات بالتاكيد لا توجد اي
مشاكل بالنسبه ما يلينا نحن من اجراءات في
السودان يعني القوات المسلحه يعني ادى
التعليمات واضحه جدا انه تسهيل كافه
الاجراءات الخاصه بين في بعض الاجراءات
طبعا ما خاصه بين خاصه بالسفارات للدول
المستضيفه دي طبعا احنا يعني
لا يمكن اتدخل فيها الدوله الحصص لطيفه
الناس عند اجراءات ايضا اما ما يلينا من
الاجراءات نحن يعني شغالين شغل استثنائي
تماما
هل تتوقعون الوصول اي طائرات خلال الساعه
المقبله الساعتين المقبلتين
نعم هنالك عدد عدد من الطلبات الطائرات من
هنا نتوقع خلال من الاخر الى طائرتين
اللواء الركن صلاح بابكر عمر ابو حسبه
قائد الفرقه 101 مشاه البحريه رئيس اللجنه
العليا لاجلاء البعثات والرعايه
الدبلوماسيه شكرا لك على هذا اللقاء
المباشر من داخل مدينه بورسودان
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
يوتيوب اعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات